it's a full speed ahead because this
time of the year is the time when these
decisions are made from a personnel
standpoint speaking of personnel where
are things with blake right now blake is
the quarterback with the jacksonville
jaguars right now
yeah he is right now and he won't be
much longer with nick foles in blake
bortles is out nick nick who nico
nick who nick nick who nick oh this
doesn't have anything to do with that oh
i thought you were talking about
somebody else
the moment they hired john d falippo to
be the offensive coordinator in
jacksonville the handwriting was obvious
nick foles would be the guy they would
pursue and fortunately for the jaguars
no one else was pursuing nick falls they
got lucky because if you have another
team that is hot on his trail then all
of a sudden the price goes up and the
price goes up and maybe it does go north
of 25 million a year as it stands four
year deal with a base value of 22
million it can be worth 100 or 22
million per year 88 million total it can
be worth 102 million over four years but
we don't know what he has to do to get
there probably a lot of things that he's
unlikely to do probably a lot of things
where if he would do them the jaguars
would be thrilled exactly paying him 102
million over four years but 22 million
when you consider where the quarterback
market currently is you know not that
long ago
we just said 22 million i mean that that
was aaron rodgers contract before last
year that's more than russell wilson's
currently making on average that's more
than ben roethlisberger is currently
making on average but so many of these
deals starting with andrew luck
continuing with derek carr matthew
stafford jimmy garoppolo kirk cousins
matt ryan aaron rodgers latest deal so
many of these deals have have just flown
past 22 million where if you're gonna
have a veteran quarterback
you're gonna be paying in that
neighborhood that's just the way it is
and that's the way it's gonna be for the
jaguars and i think they should be happy
they got a super bowl mvp chris yeah
only 22 million a year that's right got
a super bowl mvp for you know less than
the current market for what it goes for
starting quarterbacks i think that's a
positive certainly they had to take into
account too hey they're on the hook for
some money to blake bortles this year
regardless 10 million dollars right
if they post june 1st cut him they can
split it between five years this year i
mean 5 million this year 5 million next
year so i'm sure that was playing into
it too going man we're going to be on
the hook at the quarterback position for
a little more than we'd like anyways uh
but either way i think this is a great
signing for the jacksonville jaguars hey
nick foles the reason he doesn't get 25
26 million is because you know i don't
want to say he's been a flash in the pan
or anything like that but we just
haven't seen a full body of season work
from him in a long time and i think
that's why he doesn't get the big money
as we saw last year in the 2018 season
he started the season as a starting
quarterback it wasn't exactly pretty
then uh he comes in later in the year
takes over and certainly
time out time out time out time out
remember we had this conversation
remember we had the discussion about why
nick foles may have struggled early in
the year why did we think that maybe
nick foles struggled early in the year
do you remember well probably because
what he thought carson wentz was back
there ready to take his job right
so he's worried about carson wentz
hovering over his shoulder when's carson
going to be back and you agreed that is
a very real dynamic you're thinking when
are they going to put carson back on the
field wait where's carson sure and and
you take that out of the mix he's not
going to be worried about getting
benched in jacksonville this is his gig
so maybe those first couple of weeks
that same dynamic won't apply no moving
forward i i think you're right that's
fair you know but to push back against
what you're saying too i mean hey he had
a chance in kansas city he was with the
saint louis no no no no we did this last
night no okay well how he did his games
in kansas city weren't bad that you are
fake news the rams is the only the rams
year is the only year that you can point
to and say he was bad and every
quarterback that played under jeff
fisher for the rams was bad okay so
we're just setting it up it's not fake
news we're telling context into why the
guy's getting 22 million dollars
regardless of all the excuses you are
making for him this is the reality of
the situation why no one's excuse me the
guy was a super bowl mvp i wish i had
people have to make that excuse for me
you know he really is a decent guy he
was a super bowl mvp i mean my god he
was a super bowl mvp yeah he beat the
patriots i know i understand what else
does he have to do
no he was great but again you know it's
a team thing too and he's gonna help
this team out a whole lot because they
are missing a quarterback that can do
normal quarterback things uh as you've
heard me say before you know throwing
the ball down the field has not been
very good for the jacksonville jaguars
you know nick foles is certainly going
to bring that aspect to the football
team i mean one of the reasons the team
fell apart last year in jacksonville yes
they had injuries that certainly made
things tough but franchise quarterbacks
get you through those tough periods and
make some plays in the third and fourth
quarter of games to there you go okay
it's a tough period here as far as the
season's concerned hey at least we
didn't go 0-3 or 0-4 our quarterback
saved us and we you know we went 2-2
through that stretch where we were
really banged up or injured and they
didn't have that luxury in jacksonville
if the run game wasn't dominating and
the defense wasn't just absolutely
kicking the crap out of everybody it was
like uh oh wait we gotta wait for we
gotta wait we gotta hope blake has it
today and i think that's really
ultimately where jacksonville said no we
gotta move on you know the quarterback
situation has put too much pressure on
the organization and the team itself the
last two years to do to just play beyond
the defense had to play out of this
world in 2017. the run game was out of
this world in 2017. that's why they got
to the afc championship game they
finally moved on from a mistake they had
in blake bortles and i think nick foles
really with john d filippo is a great
signing by them and and really going to
give them a different aura as a football
team altogether
you know any time that a guy who played
quarterback at a fairly high level i'll
give you fairly high level any time that
that guy assesses another quarterback as
not put on earth to throw a football
which was your assessment of blake
bortles the
the the bar is low in jacksonville for
what it's going to take for this team to
have a decent passing attack and you
know we've seen what nick foles can do
and i think i kind of like the fact
that nick foles
continues to be disrespected continues
to be demeaned continues to be
overlooked that only is going to fuel
him to go to jacksonville and be even
better
jaguars fans have lost their minds over
this like folks you have had blake
bortles and you've been defending him
for five years
why are you resisting a guy who won the
super bowl mvp award it's amazing to me
i mean and really what other options did
the jaguars have they ain't getting
tyler murray no tom brady isn't
available nick foles is the best
available option and you can argue right
especially after what we saw last year
with what case keenum did in denver and
kirk cousins did in minnesota
maybe this works out in the long run
much better for the jaguars waiting a
year and getting foals versus getting
one of the guys who was available in
2018. yeah right guys available in 2018
what is this this also saves them you
know they don't have to be in the
quarterback conversation for the number
seven pick in the draft now i mean they
don't have to be maybe they still are
but it doesn't make them desperate for
the quarterback in the draft too i think
that's where the smart play is and in
jacksonville i mean i just think nick
foles is going to fit the style of play
to which they want to play perfectly
it's going to be a lot like what we i
think we saw the eagles how they played
the last two years in the playoff
stretch right they're going to run the
ball they're going to play smart defense
and in certain situations they're going
to go hey big big nick foles just stand
in that pocket and you know make some
big throws here and there and we need
you to and that's what he's done for the
philadelphia eagles and clutch times and
i think that's going to continue for him
in jacksonville
yeah look i'm excited for for what this
could mean man they're getting backlash
about this in jacksonville yes what have
they won i don't understand
i just i i don't know
yeah i they want someone other than nick
foles but you know once they see what he
can do and once they see that he's not
just a guy who's going to pad the stats
when they're down 30 points in the
fourth quarter he's a guy who's going to
help them win games and he's going to
bring equality to the locker room that
it desperately needs i think that he
will command respect
and i think that he will provide a brand
of leadership that may help get past
some of these rough spots we've seen in
recent years where guys aren't getting
along i don't think blake bortles had
that desire or ability to be the leader
or the the swagger to pull it off no i
think he was already listening to blake
bortles i think why why wouldn't
everybody listen to him
right well i think that was part of the
dysfunction because i think a lot of the
team down there felt like wait we're uh
you know here here i am mr defensive
tackle or defense or end or cornerback
when i don't do my job man i seem to get
the wrath but the quarterback doesn't
seem to do his job a lot and we just
keep throwing them out there hey here's
more money here you go oh hey you've
never done anything wrong
you saw i just i think that's part of
what was going on down there the
frustrations of that position were
filtering across the team where there
were the the defense is having fights in
the locker room from everything i know
about going
why are we held accountable how come if
we don't hold the team to 10 points
we're in we're in trouble as a football
team or the defense gets scolded for not
absolutely dominating jacksonville is in
win
now mode their team is set up to make a
super bowl run jaylen ramsey you know
yannick and gawkway aj bouillier miles
jack all these guys are about to be in
the prime of their career you
jacksonville fans you don't want a young
quarterback right now and have to wait
for him to develop and nick foles by far
is the cream of the crop at quarterback
for free agency so why wouldn't you want
him that's where i would just push back
against the jacksonville fans so well
you have covered all bases as it relates
to nick foles you have trashed him and
both praised him in the same segment so
we can check every possible box
i just gave some context to why maybe he
didn't get 26 or 27 million dollars a
year that's all i did
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports